[Music]
m valentin
elle me developer advocate for google
cloud platform and to day will talk
about performance and will take back
performance of program
whitling au running et le public cloud
and have lost lives and probably ou
fetter innovates time to one for live
questions your  please come to me just
after the presentation in albite at the
disc s first al shaer mainside beats
what we want to optimize in cheeky
new american series observe de
performance offer cloud architecture un
discover witty convenance veste explains
actu recounting six experiences by our
youth and finally  we will have a look at
how we kahn observe improve our company
is written in go
what is performance tuning you pretty
and fight working and some things that
is law un making and faster product
symbol wild wings extra and high sum
possible benefits of improving
performance  is to increase the throne
foot a cost of khost fits beats
all fake asses single the most
important gold which is to offer better
user experience
qm en second armor precious dan
machine second users a very high
expectations of speed if the experience
sloggi service they will get frustrated
en de will leave de architectural
fenioux software systems designed for
certain level of performance is always
the result of experience and into his
own reflexes what kind of latency
which would expect in theory
however the man who are more relevant you
as soon as this system exists even before
it initial roll is and german open
against addict into his own
aymen experience of  developer in
aggravate between sean whyte most of the
times they are displayed current lease
number one in die zeit date my super
this martin tweet your turn out to be dead
wrong and the other and i'm happy and
great food date my my home and finally
provided me with inside closer to the
reality dyson interesting correlation
between code quality and performance one
you successfull rfact  or we are code to
make it faster ue au fun to make it
clear hours to death cuts hold you
find and the making it faster
east asia the author louise and
under instruction tattoo artist previously
executed in fine also be consumed
possible  optimization now i've become
more obvious under easy to implement and
others and if you prefer ignore quest
for performance you will have to give up
simplicity  quality where it is done from here the
blue line of the going down as in so far
as the god will become more difficult to
read and stories and to the
baltics brutal death in delhaize flexible so it's
kind of a offered to are you going to go
now world ii bat automated test
designing strong automated test is
necessary in order to make optimization
refactoring without introducing
regression of bugs to de sentheim
de defense you know between service time and
response time an  di was not that many
people that great diwan in milliseconds
cyr as de time it took force de services
to process in common requests des six de
services time it might very well be date
de la tannery experience by the users
who was actually seven angel
milliseconds de  you there may have the
connection
or the request kuzbik used by some
datacenter front-end in visible
both servers instance
until all the other qde request have
been served this total waits for it if in
the response time and it is always
bigger dan de  services time has it also
includes de network ran trip in the
killing time  6 milliseconds this format
and total weight having fruits resources
is everything is fine of monitoring
system of the individual resources
requests from all users may be displayed
t  ogether and the complex interfaith a
customs officer at the click in two singles request
indeed everything luxury fine way our
surface where at the user willy experience
is certainly not a meaningful pdil au
diwan jordan twenty milliseconds
because of the cure anti design of the
resource page he has  redid this
fruit lease if konture and west ham the total
response time i want to seconds of a
rhizome for improvement and the beast
fixed and probably are klein
front server work and not the speed
improvement of the existing d'accueil
mmorpg sweet and go for  example in line
in the most critical at 7 strokes of
results and the dramatic at the best
response times the way amaizing all this
and what does it right to do with go
program this is not an herbal tea go
software is you pretty servers
convenience of  servers convenience art
where we have the most accessible
basic training
server performance service logs 3 6 6 3 tells me
too easy to phone world to fall onesel  f
into thinking that when the server iis
splendor of a magic the two roles system
is fast and the user to harding pleasant
seamless responsive experience the
discipline at the trot
of the victims looking only adserver
latency is open in ternet the application
to google helped identive  a notice date
however does not like to play staking thirty
seconds to renders of use of war staring
at the blank screen completely a
senior southern official javascript or has
performing houairi paint over and over
for some ways and a boat s completely
invisible all this server monitoring  de
fer step to achieve the meaning crowd
evaluated fine performance in the same
architecture datex into account de
clientes device workload de bowser cash
de network latency and number of one
trip du twin server side anne klein saïd
aïdi alioui hot you're the one system
will  you there monitoring to have the
browser collect valuable metrics this we
don't have to which only of the server
metrics and away 100e  what they te lot of
the world claude of the latency asia
shift and due form of server side to the
cloud side and we have to take this fact
intake and more generally focus single
the users in the good aedian a quant du
vert entre 16.10  axium users first now
let's have a look at the hope the
ability to ling the boys in
google cloud cloud platform web
console include stack driver logging
witikon solidays de request cloggs india
de applicative logs it off your computer
stakeholders as follows en jeans que
bernetti  saint jean de waiters leaves
including nerves wild time you can
filter 2 view bike and run and bike and
world and by day for each request and
line the request your senses oral polio
of size of the payload of time stamp
india aunty trend  he
offers services times is super useful
will find member that it's over
fraktion of the response times it
barely made me jean staune dab request
have been automatically instruments ty
he fa  ut a click in de bluelink in de
latency
we will see the water for review of
world and pierrick old to catch the ring
the processing of the request to i love
waterfall caps des providers his match
inside in single view date and even
hockey ou nder  tellme young television rights
abend hockey d'estag driver 3 view
integrates and ideo is clean dissipate
web console thing me forgiven request
what he ping calls were made in which
order to hollande de touques in the way
of control or competitor of top weight
button  applicative thing logs white
inside the waterfall diagram
actually leave a corner of the strong future observed
bill thies of span style me what
happened soul of the ogs tell me why mde
specific example of total await
6-1 6-2 all but the five years
consist  olmos in size ali in one
datastore in hybrid titles eynden all
datastore crisis we have you would
place is accessible or even cash
flows in superfast has an ode to 2
bottleneck in the data store an  d there's
no pointing to speed up my mum operational cash
you can also know this that the last or
datastore crisis ron concurrent lee
which is good idea
or is this possible ouch strongly
encourage everyone to say tap of
automatic expert of all the love to
be queen
this string exports is also kohl's
think when the quarry uzbek way you
don't have the default redemption
period of heart is only and you can use
sequel to where i find great
performance inside over large
or shut period of time and deeply
switcher words like  that
and even at the hours of the 6th back end of
the website brittany ngo running in app
engine standards in the late in six
columns of static at 7 milliseconds
1050ef extremely lola time 6 jets
actually serve internal tidiane sy and
faye bluelink clique to favorites
quest to  view this details a86 and
autophobic country Thursday evening 9 consists of a
key control data store creil ok fine
nothing fanci d'iférouane to find some
things they too  k length irene filter
show in trees yes yes by the way latency
ok on this one was not re les fastes
what was it bat hockey even cache even
kg datastore something that can be
iverson processing
or precisely servers leaves weirdness
hockey ayam et al rai des raves  things
to be coire is probable that a figure
of pyrite is so i can ask question in
decorated like in it will for all the
request that were not made by bob lee
kosa i don't care drummer jean boots in
date were not static at  this evening
whose star treiziste fixed point what what
were the request that was more from key
access to rs 1 what are there
latency havrais there are elsewhere the tantie
will leave history and his six co-
written with where we should have known
evening  a time this europe and slash has
been the most access page
le havrais de l'attention ou only by the
night only closed and 10 seconds
that's quick and max attention was the
bad for android but the five years ok this
slogan klimov axis fr  équenté axis species
of birds rss en pointe
which is not wheels and the user facing
butt and of the jury face time they can't
take up to
everything we take his 25 years but big
to fail khan one of the few are chris
ware we  'd like to insert hour of spain
in the right one of all for example it is
necessary to burn these dream countries computer sean
hoare hot duration between two
rated events opensuse let you know this
with it started driver xporter from google
cloud documentation thing how to do  this
for hardly jean standard will do benzin
flex for computing in focus bernetti
saint jean
opensuse indicates competitors
opensourcing to open source
the wanted joann sfar 6-2 and plunders where
they converge indecisive grenews
cloud computing force observe empowered
community conceptualize of best view to
understand  latency and offer
including in the water for love you in
this it people example or chat person
of the server latency west africa
service times note response times
comm  e if this n 6 against alcohol or
external services works well
that everyone regret he said b 10 lots
at betis log in iraq and see for
opportunities for improvement force to
a staple better heidi of latency and
of each of my  bananas 6hif my
database is expected to response and her
and john milliseconds
batmag measure man show date ethikwear i
actually take two hundred milliseconds
des niners and something should be fixed
in the external database maybe kruyt un
index if i'm looking at the speed up  the
database accessible without hunting and
things in the server god only by doing
up and the database of total latency and
Christmas tips used the beat it snow
length ni at 2050 in order to witness
repetita access to of five services where
they defend parameters in pays d  'aude
and tesla of the
various dates and the service accepts bat
cause at ease if it accepts mini
order a single and pico den debaty
cole will be faster than the individual
kohl's h  ere we are calling services by
free time sequence scholly yes stéphane
parameters one two three
but we can do better by transfer in the
sound of in bad guys and data asking for
months of work to de services by putting
single i like all we say d'  only improved
from total auntie 10150 and intuitive
des makes perfect sense of causes
somavie cost like the network ran thrips
of the network awaits him if as pau nantes
authentic to sion will not exceed are now be
only ones instead of three times yes
sometimes chief disposition  vahirua ping
of commands a transaction
however bashing in transactions ' out
of ifrane concept jackson a bat atomicity
india bad thing is about living economizes
of scale 10 and zoua de baigts inc and
looked like when using hugo claus
code library code change is not
very complex we just need to know that
it happened to make things faster most
of the times and the road shows that
making of few expensive and competing fish farms
bed and faster t  han win
dance et consoli please note that i'm
not looking back cypihot local band
computational i'm talking about
dispatching concurrentes world to the
external world and by which has been
outside of my cure in server comme pau
nantes il michael the cold tout service
bis à logic lee completely indipendente
from de database kohl's and from two
emails operation
sohail khan decide to run services bics
concurrent lies and save summit the
seconds of switzer operation depend on
each of completion on the a400m
hall competitors clean
as the bats colt or services  by starck
immediate bed in law defines twinzer
email has been cents and effective libya
as fruit of total duration in the
same with or without the cole tout
service bi france esteem paul example of
parallel eising tout une dependence
blocks of computer and ice edge est use
the  white group to and of them
commands channels choose the
causes of chanel details are people and
truck and huguette w  ade wade groupe à
stratford the only way method du
tonneau had to incremente tu donne tout
dit crument d' un wait to let them and
go routine move and when all star qaf
completed non please ask you safe in the
email sending operation is more synchro
news  corp is synchronous used by nature
in my opinion
yves Saturday n'goni mail temporal y
canton by aurélie sfez necessarily reason
than the users can't do much with a
training in server stupidity job to
try and a few minutes
she suggests date we  had emails
operation all and ask you use in google
cloudtest hand and return immediate lee
once again saving precious human
milliseconds of tasque will be executed
and synchronize after the fairy queen
is written and it will deal with the
witcher
difference
work with cloud task has nothing to do
with the go
synchronized task typically involves
serial eising sums parameters into the
tales of pierrick west
date will be process by another
offering them ap
now expose 26 the result
total of two hundred milliseconds
instead of nine hundred in the huge wind
of cancer device  de without you sing
in illo louvain l'assemblee code without
riding the underlying hardware and
without even kering and
digging oats armenia cypihot cause janeiro and is more
useful to performance test run in
these machines configuration
asus introduction keep in mind that public
cloud offer virtual machine witcher
convenient but don't give you crowd
control over the underlying hardware
heaven and stealth very good
average waits 6 you may experience elsewhere
variance danish dedicated hardware
seed disturbs test huge
charisma and disturbs user experience
application  louis toning au cread
mosaic in which it style in the color
4 because of cop  yright concerns
semailles intimate will be mona lisa in
2004 they will have to by myself and i need
to specify all parameters the
resolution of time in pixels
can we play under 12h promising the
resolution of the time in pixels in
count of tales date where they make  the
will of the result a mosaic will
open the diploids this way back
to barely jean standard life will ris ques
lowely horizontal water resolution of
duty 4 in i lay up l'aude the picture of
my girlfriend mona lisa the generated
spoiler  alert is hot work and it
should be fast ya crisis
ok i chuckle services in the street
looks like this is neither
business size animals faith of mona lisa
will try again this time recruiting
horizontal resolution of ethics ce
conte remember et fizi slower fast with
the way fly servers error the server
a counter of an error of notes as
bloated west to ineo it the
local life of the og hadi partovi had
bad things me what does it says
that seniors in 8 16 exceeded soft
memory limit of one giant road
megabytes because the f one class of
barely jean 1606 of have much memory
especially produce this big immediate this
problem in itself and diplomas the same
just saint jean de parameters instanz
class  said it vertical scalability
thing of the biggest instance vélib all
in app engine standard the djsl a smell
a windows eric hosted horizontal
resolution 9 and icade
so this might think thank you fifteen
second beta spoiler alert and louis
triaud works
india flaws click to zoom  cheese made
fall of little four of the six great and
this would make actually a very good
background pictures of you wanted to
print poster tout à plat toi poster
printing company had given ideas to
resolutions be French or ask for
more 4 one hand sedan 34 that  it's our
total number of 4 except that we offer
a strong Corsican egg online printing and would
need of the cat to be at least the
hundred antoine theate pixel  s woods has it
10 and deserve their star fail and
waasland of the titles the title l1 two
errors but this joy look the same
exceeded memory of the east of one
gigabyte the what do i do aya diploids
healthy application to you bernetti saint
jean
let's  paint shop and a whole request one
be between ni 4 wild and one of the
pixel label you are out by both to
print of poster saddens all metals
sign that my god sow and will take her
eyes face and the can / you that it's
only a  few bernetti this sun cluster
is salty in sight czech kloster 1 av
that belgium and czech services had
indicated hu
claude wolter that might be in arabic the
deployment of the underlying a
consultant jean machine stand his brothers
nick and see that each of might not have
it  virtual type use and fifty gigabyte
of memories pride gigabytes
its turbine off to produce mona lisa ya
six volunteers ty satie on young and
will be able to say that failed to the
printing company finally we'll see  a
range of hours at den haag resolutions
or don't use the web browser because
displaying multi gigabit pixels
gigapixels pictures in the brothers to
two antennas to where she battles than to
new school for that because the server
indicated will end of the world no problem
and will get my life with many 1 billion
pixels and this in date its pressing
ok but ricco
tac driver profilers company in we
left and i'll explained minutes in car
i dat say it very little extra
configuration with a confession profilers
agent collection more  information about
what is going on in the city or and in
the memories of the computing stentys
oil smile filter by two day
one undecided people of flame graff
of the mosaic like catechesis to mona
lisa wood cate that we've seen and we'  ll
see in a few minutes it authorizes 10
beat bgc horizons process function
inside of prospecting my code isin
another function que le raïs 4 how
they lot you of the times of suspense
codi  ng all pnj that will be in a few
minutes kolstad there is too much performance
council in servers let application
the pass start it remains response date is
much higher than usual server causes
is warm up sapeurs either
because the app april to traffic at 9:07
servers instanz as to start
or because of traffic increasing en deux
autos skyler decided to start in
extremis ans
il me experience go application time
must fastco all-stars azy don't need
gvm inde also because thanks to the
standard de la librarie des  youyous
pretty don't need to lose angels of
megabytes of library bananas 6 for
example jersey apps deploys
standard denim tablecloths with all-stars
datacenter everything we all have
counts online date protego de
goldstein swde bad servers less  with
the west and cloud run this week
which you graduate as tennis must
have servers the mdc platforms huge
a week they want my specificity
with cloud run angie who cultivate there
ver  ticals vertical scalability will be
chosen new york as machine with more
memory one death six countries to chaos and
steel skate or 0 and the server the
wish not the works look at the go
tooling of all green touch at arnott
specific to the cloud
of cameron in  safe development of
laptops henderson said m
in douala and this perfect li fine all soft
we are performing exploration and your
own computer sorting member that it's
more roundup sales and
production in value goes up to something else
measurements show production
sometimes 10  workstation shovels
measures months and well as my best in
chains ngozi if it makes us
automatic test olg to the programmer a
familiar with his command line is in
progress said or explore performance in
test files at this standard testing package
played by night line with the
performance tooling madymo today we will
you this will use goat sb3 member date
of thank you can be used for any go
executed bear the bear and came back i  ndecise to
oyo grooves benchmarks integrated inn
de go thesis on order with additional
flag dc the powerful performance future
of the goat howling white tout
benchmarks calling 5 threshold
nba respectively and see which one of
the tourist de fast s
un saw 6 heures tout fashion day and  by
the do the same thing that time to
determine if the world database here it
is contained in this article
spoiler alert a cherry yes the world
database pierre andrieu ni test are
shake that it is true indeed
on lira the two benchmark fort et i am
by test fans
yes they work specif overrun the
fics the tests and a dess bihar passing
of 6 good night sound the benchmark so
this is telling us are you going to work by
day or run millions of tons in
any case in April while playing d  'antoine
10 nanoseconds according to birds
executed 30 emilian times
just like red join android
milliseconds which means that in
disguise string others contains
story  as fast has the regular
expression which is good to know if you
want to decide which one two poutine
production trice t61 execution tresseur
it works by instruments thing de
programs tout produit
binary file containing activity of it is
cheap et au corps over period of time
in  the city your idols and running de
garbage collector easytronic de function
and what is de coltrane 10 in the city
au band se console task you can see that
only one of the bigger is active and
other words are hayden honda and toyota
august date de samse control  computer and
made and 10 passes
we know volts cpu core i9 only lure
of the go runtime
jason involve eni competitors if only
one cypihot corps is working at any
given times now decide an example
competing offers like farting chain using
several goro think you can see  that old
school
abhisit scans be good or bad beat it
does it mean date to program and fish
and having auto your routines this
release y thing and sync  hronise in
with each other can lead the canton alone
a float expansive context sweeting
quite often inappropriate granularity
force de goro tin can lead to work
performance with force bio aux dames de
saintes se console tu a qu'on one
single cpi au corps de best multi core
relative performance customs and co
routine performs doing almond offs i
can't always be for waiting to each and
then leasing and mutex computer crime thing
wade group song au north and the
benchmark once again this time in stream
hunted execution and out putting ben-  ari
file country of othe out ok the mosaics
generation mona lisa ok great in the
old results that everything else was
p6t6 strong axes my window andy white
and the five days of night hockey so
what we affair
quite the author a training are  at
two weekend tops if they reached x
horizontal axis of time because it's
you seconds 7/10 duration of might
benchmark because my code is run from
wine to strong glass on ci  nq years so we can
see any given times now menigot routine
does not exist
we can see the rip soa aux mines à une
match memory was actually communes comme
un orange
enders had the good ones all of corinne
times of atsem green we are like that  at
manitoba rating system fred at
distance running in 2 batches for each processor
at fort and dissipate in case and when
it's fx abhisit rider and we can see
what it is doing that time series fight
league benni were here when louis riel
trucks  and ride inhabitants of bissau and
oise at a time in coding sums pnj or
using the standard from the end of august
another life you can see that only one
cpu core to the assets because my my code of
ethics we wear coding sums pnj and
radicals dinsheim jpeg
yes des inputs mona lisa that was gpec
hockey and there are for life processor
because à la force unicorn en mesh
laptop
nabli profs qui profite le profiling
data formate volley-ball out of the box
ingo let's have a look at the little prof
six countries where profilers from these countries
reprofiling works by sampling and tinkers
relatively small runtime overhead every
now and then of kernel scene steve kroft
final in two special handler of the
go runtime gaiters sticks 13 of one
curan clearing go data routine seven
off of  this could this is over period
of time contains rudy statistical a
formation date is used to produce this
graph of the function string or gold to
know much time i spent in each function
in the result in graf and from the box it
works an explicit the displays of the
number of seconds spent inside the code
of the function of total times paint in
the function including the home phone
calls by writing people tales of the
total running times recorded running
the benchmark in the very effective or
and gas and a training ace of
function harold  many times over at the short
period of time at the top of the will find
the program in three pines and your own
important functions at the bottom
haro  ld library standards
function and the system code of duration
of each box consist in the some of the
office and see by your time place of the
shipping time of the function in god's
discount only the times actualize sorrows
using the six pilots of tam spence
waiting for you can dance
des stein instruments ti de quiz cypihot
profilers of du prof du web iphone ipod
profs we are important all our hearts
at all about the result the number from
de benchmarks 6 number the goodbye
instrumentation here and only interested
in touch visualization goto  le petit
prof
ok le titille p6t6 ws for my window of
the white and the binary file
and other profs hockey can we say we can
say that my benchmark this process
works which mosaic credit
duke ninety person of the total times
ok my own  code colorist 4 and all parcel
nineteen person of the total time in of
pnj in code in which is the sharing of
standards of library and which
hardly we said to i  ndes the processing
and a comfort fifty three person of the
total times of the six as and the evaluation bol
insight
if he wanted to optimize my own code
hays would only be able to optimize
lets dan twenty person of the world
claude de bottleneck et le standaard
library function of pnj en coding which
is not my god and which are is
contradicted by going live to multiple
causes because it is called only ones à
diane d'off the mosaic generation
however know that ainhoa de coding des stick
qu i decided to not buffer  de
output the only advantage of buffering
in my previous code was to lock the
precise number of light sweet and that
was de lynx of the bike buffer il
faut give de response letter' directly to the
process function de brothers in arms in
the data stream  has it is being in
coded six goudurix
user causes feedback strong six which
tease pleads match ringers in before a
mastiff white lies in proof of total
response times because the coding
effectively par adélaïde with the
response data bling laden loaded by the
climb problem a dit michèle alliot en
trichant bat expected performances d'art
is also sometimes some emotional
investments and some prejudice on this
topic
this gesture or stick to the fact 1 to
discover by 40  bottleneck wood text from
moss time in my or sky is everything
that is not bottleneck can wait
now the flame graff slam graff in the
fine silhouette or visual eyes from
profiling data and was invited by to
brendan greg holland all the green zone
in it is so  we will james deseine
commands to the effort ghoul little teacher
he said
then ok fault click in view lazy
graff made switches connects nice and
is not completely obvious from first time
or here in flaine graf 22 horizontal axis
and kz2 between them present
chronological  times however the way it
off and ispan and proportional everything
total duration spent executing
distinction smile ariav everything
benchmarks benchmark process a
benchmark  process in memory and its clique
on this one can say that my own code
colorize 4 they led by tav the
total 10 coding is said to be peg of mona lisa
is like fifteen person of
npc in codina jihad is consistent with ghana either
it is
curious taiwan  all in pictures with andy
murray andy fear
positive in europe qu aux
sums awaits him if he is why should i look at
the flame graf
he does belgium the display the same
training to regulate himself harpy prograf
say they this stereotype schools work to
work in the morning works india stone
ainslie tonight i'm saying they to the
stereotypes that stick vocation d sleep
in the morning good the beat india
stones and dance all night indices and
zoua de pi prof graff looked like and
figure in simulation like time in some
people inactivity in sum people a
vocation are works on example
slip art kolda everyone but not at the
same time of the day even with complete
this offer duration annotations 10
grave deux rives and 9 un  e formation to
know is going to the beach of wales le
box et sparte of work days off hors
parts of fashion days of may be some
bitche activity and white
it prosper list act only under
vacations des boxes and we also discover
date vacations des tipis clear invoice
bit more sleep and work the bottom line
is lazy kraft a very beautiful life
like fire and also super useful to find
the root cause of  the expectation cie something it is
necessary suspicious to be successful sophie
au program is not correctly explained
by trees and rip off you want to use the
perv all the pacific competitors six
competitors it's a parallelism art
powerful tools to do is everything that
once
un air des crises de total l'
attend seehofer request and we've seen lot of
the times paint in web services and spent
waiting for ethical twitter in disguise
de performance is n  ot related at all to
the number of shipping and not right
into the speed of its ipo corp was that
yeah their extreme the useful to be able
to external cevenol passes and
concurrent looting the staples just like a
test for verona from dattakhel detector
ok you'  re a le droit des our beasts
were super useful to stay on a trike
because when you work and performance
optimization are stretched between two
competitors six years old yann l
ngô thinh à nu entre du subtil boys and
it is really useful to detect the bug
as soon as  possible davies north thing
as the homeless data racing au we have
to be careful here is the quick check
list of commons performing bottlenecks
and how we can enjoy them in good
ever popular execution of use
instructions obviously hunting
eliminating useless code is the good as
it is pleased eight names network ayew
external to psychosis a relatively
extremely expansive michael zweig is to
make as your request as possible
everythi blog note  ng will hunting for network
response reading form and writing to de
file system and flower and most of what
we do in memory and in the sea pillot this
jersey device is to work as much as you
can in memory and to do your eyes to the
countless qingwei  pictures when a
young talent days of goo routine waiting
for each other in the perfect
rizaï pfoten necessaries according to business
and to limit this excessive need for
constanze communication between
routine
ice edge is created
at work of the world cup in the long run it's
murky like  this file for speed ou
comme un one million computer to perform
et saaq de launchpad millions of euros
10.7 foot by little bit ravi and cost et
it's my [ __ ] ou start small number of
work r go routine say i hate un grave
each worker  process we see knights of
the total l'aude pretty sequence asking
for memory tour operating system is the
notorious liste lo operation smile
il tous à l'eau kate l'ardd chain of
memories in single called the built i  n
mike sanchez turns and use memory passing
buffer an argument to the processing
works
orso using hen from the thing package
when you prove towards useful hip hop
stack 10 specific parts straight up
compay them we know that a lot casting
rip it expensive as of date at  looking at
the star is almost free world green de
rip en what goes to the stack twice
is not in tweet yves are local
variables but escape to the rip if we
take it from a pasito a hand hymn
and 10 panzi campaigned their
slaves  hours enough to variable rate teacher
two years escape on it is safe
very small in stack 10 begins
scientific evidence the 2 go specifications
does not contain the world this
horrible tackle use extra jesse flag date m to
determine local luigi is worth birds
escape or not  to adapt the function scop
tulik leaves references regular
expressionart great balls to hoffen
overkill lighthouse give and need somail
advice is big little boy game one you
can
fon  works like a think thank all inkl
new york post
yes say can be mean when it the
fun do they work very small and
called millions of time this to
specifications does not toc atolls of
buy in linings fighting years and their age
itron very specific internal  rules when
it comes to decide if u smile funktion
one by inline
or not chasing de in line up to have it
in line specific rock funk and has
become populace porte also implementing
details are subject to transform
goreux release to another
de like to 5 mac colleague david cage aux
fous is wonderful presentation tools
demo it would find your thing to day and
all so why do you have to et mode
clickers because i'm all sides et
ou il n'a n'été que oui de gowlings  wedgwood
design for cloud computing yes
scalability in mind and ecosystems is
rich and performance tuning and hollywood
no twin prof the experience of users un
make the world the better place
starwizz is important new skie  s
discover de bottleneck fix a drop it
thank you very much the listening
[Applause]
[Music]